the New York Times now targeting
Republican wives the times editorial
board member is mocking male GOP
candidates for having their wives appear
in their campaign ads calling it a
gimmick that's insulting to female
voters adding quote cue the emergence of
Ghazi campaign ads starring the wives of
Republican Senate hopefuls getting
personal about their Hobbies gag we are
expected to absorb the message if the
candidate's wife and the mother of his
children thinks he's a good guy then it
must be so spare me so Jessica we often
talk about uh misogyny as if it's male
on female but Democrat women can be
really mean really mean how does it feel
representing a misogynistic party feels
great
[Laughter]
okay
we do this dance every time that there's
a Democrat on the cover of Vogue or
Vanity Fair it's like what about Melania
she's so beautiful and yes she is so
beautiful but this relates back to
the fact that Democratic women don't
want to support people who they believe
are anti-woman and the policies that
they support and everybody uses their
family on both sides of the aisle of
course but there have been some things
that have come out like from Blake
Masters who's running against Mark Kelly
he had to scrub his entire website of
all of this you know no exceptions for
rape and incest you know no abortion at
all and that's suddenly gone and he came
out right after that was an ad with his
wife and his kids to humanize him and I
get it that it's smart politics but I
believe what that writer is doing and
what we're talking about is that
supporting women who do not make it
better to be a woman in this country
because these policies are not things
that will help us
makes sense to me Dana just did you
notice that basically she said it's not
a difference in opinion you're immoral
like you no you're saying that [ __ ]
because she doesn't support the things
you believe you she does not deserve the
same respect you do yeah and you said
that Jessica literally I think zero of
those words came out of my mouth I I
condensed it it is it is a strange thing
if you believe that life begins at
conception I don't think that's immoral
yeah um but that is the debate that's
being set up right and so one of the
reasons you see the Republicans pushing
back is to say well wait you want to be
able to kill a baby up until birth
that's extreme so you're gonna see this
play out and I would just remind you
that wives have been a part of politics
for thousands of years remember in the
Bible yes Pontius pilate's wife said
don't get involved in that crucifixion
business did he yes she did wow she did
and so that this is this goes back a
long time look you could even look to
the fact that Hillary Clinton you know
Cece Monica Lewinsky hello what about
that but how disgusting was that exactly
they didn't they didn't support the
woman in that case at all and then you
look at today John fetterman's wife
basically accompanies him to every
single thing now he has a health problem
he does but should that make us gag that
she's shepherding him away from the
Press Jill Biden Shepherd's uh Joe Biden
away from the Press Corps all the time
he hasn't done an interview in over 200
days in a democracy where you have
basically Free Speech as you're
underpinning so I think we have seen a
lot more offensive things in the past
than a strong pro-life woman basically
saying that I support my husband yeah to
be fair though Dr Jill is a pediatric
neurosurgeon who once actually split
siamese twins in the back of a pickup
truck going down a narrow Winding Road
during an earthquake so uh how dare you
how dare you but there's a there is a
double standard here judge it's like a
democratic wife and I'm again I'm using
Jessica's direct quotes or heroic and
Republican wives are submissive step
forward wives I'm using Jessica's exact
backwards yes yes and I agree with you
Greg I certainly do I love Jessica but I
agree with you no look the claim that
these women are doing nothing for other
women is just it's just not accurate
there is there is a tremendous there are
a tremendous number of women who believe
that life is sacrosanct that you know
it's immoral to have an abortion at nine
months or it's six months so you know
stop with the morality High Ground uh
but I also think I mean having run for
office five times you know what you do
is you put your family and the dog or
dogs on the on the palm card that you
hand out that's what you do I think the
hate that we're experiencing from the
left gagging about wives the hate toward
Melania Trump was so it was so
disingenuous it was so unfair here's a
woman who was an immigrant who spoke
five languages who could run circles
around people who were making fun of her
who was a model who was stunning and
she's disgusting I mean that's just hate
there's no justification for that she
didn't do anything to deserve that kind
of hate but so having said all that you
know I think people ought to just you
know leave the spouses out but in the
end uh they're very much part of the
picture you know Jesse when you run for
office will you be using your family uh
some sort of edge over say somebody like
me when I run against you who has no
family I don't even have a dog yeah you
bet your wife's just a secret weapon a
fish
doing well by the way thanks for asking
yeah good luck putting your fish in your
campaign yeah when I got my whole family
sitting there looking beautiful
I told Trump the reason I voted for him
because I wanted Melania as first lady I
told him that to his face and then I
said if he ever divorces Melania I'm
voting for DeSantis I told him that
through his face
JD Vance's wife is a corporate litigator
who went to Yale law and clerked for
Kavanaugh and John Robert Works she's
Indian American she's smart she's young
and she's very pretty this other wife
the guy's running for Senate out in
Colorado Joe o'daya's wife is
Mexican-American and she just cut a
Spanish language radio ad I think the
real reason the New York Times isn't
like these guys wives is because they're
young they're smart and they're diverse
and you can't really characterize a
republican as being a racist and a
sexist and a fascist if they have all
these young beautiful smart attractive
diverse wives also they're mad because
they're happy yes yeah that too
Democrats have happy marriages oh that's
a big lie
it's early but it's been good
no Hunter's happy that's not for
marriage that's marriage hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else